ayuda a los europeos deben salir de su
ingenuidad son palabras del presidente
francés emmanuel mccomb en referencia a
las nuevas prioridades estratégicas de
washington es su primer pronunciamiento
tras dos semanas de tensiones en las
relaciones con eeuu la imprevista
decisión de australia de cancelar un
contrato con francia para la compra de
submarinos y establecer en su lugar una
asociación estratégica con estados
unidos y reino unido- provocó la ira de
parís que en respuesta retiró a sus
embajadores en washington y canberra y
constatamos que desde hace más de 10
años eeuu se ha concentrado mucho en sí
mismo y tiene intereses estratégicos que
se están reorientando hacia china y el
pacífico es su derecho es su soberanía
no soy yo pero seríamos ingenuos o más
bien cometeríamos un terrible error si
no quisiéramos considerar todas las
consecuencias y ver esto por nosotros
mismos
el mandatario dio sus declaraciones tras
firmar un contrato de venta de tres
fragatas a atenas una apuesta por la
soberanía militar y estratégica de
europa compartida por el primer ministro
griego
señor presidente la historia nos une al
igual que la geografía el mediterráneo y
europa para la que estamos construyendo
un futuro mejor que el nutrición
trabajar por europa esa es nuestra
misión y luego fue la visión la venta de
las embarcaciones militares llega en
momentos de también fuertes tensiones
entre grecia y turquía tras una disputa
territorial en el mediterráneo oriental
francia niega que dicha adquisición
contribuya a una escalada en la zona
disputada